[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing real relationships george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print podcast on ramsey networks is
my co-host today as we take your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five aaron in
lexington starting off this hour hi erin
how are you
yeah
first time caller
well we're honored to have you how can
we help
well we
we just came into a little bit of money
as a settlement that i'm sure they're
going to pay taxes on
that's about 210 000 so
just trying to figure out what we should
do with it we've already debt free that
we've used your plan over the years not
faithfully but we've used it and
everything we've got is paid off and the
mortgage has paid off and so i'm just
trying to figure out what to do with
this
you know what's the
best way not to pay taxes on it because
obviously i think
on this is going to put us over another
tax bracket that we're going to pay a
lot of taxes on it
yeah well i mean there's what was the
settlement for
uh
just a
previous
work
that was disclosed
what i mean was it like a workers comp
type situation
there was some past employment
a past employer
yeah were you hurt
physically
yeah it's going to be taxed it will be
taxed on it how do you know yeah
well they were already in time
that doesn't matter
how do you know it's going to be taxed
them giving you a 1099 doesn't mean that
you are taxed there's two types of
settlements there's punitive and
compensatory
okay compensatory is compensation if
this is lost wages or compensation that
they're paying you on or back wages that
they didn't pay you accurately then
that's going to be taxable punitive may
or may not be taxable and so you need to
talk to your taxes your tax advisor to
be sure your old company or your lawyer
shouldn't be giving you tax advice you
need to go get that on your own number
one but let's pretend it is taxable we
need to calculate what the taxes are
going to be and the first thing we're
going to set the taxes aside out of it
so that the money's sitting there next
april and you're ready to go right you
write the check
right and then that leaves you the rest
of it to do something with but you are
not you you don't have medical bills due
to an injury is associated with this
right
no okay all right all right well there's
only you said you're out of debt
completely you don't have a payment in
the world including your house which
means you've got all the options in the
world and so there's only three things
you can do with this money you can give
some you can save some you can spend it
and i would encourage you to do all
three if this is just kind of fun money
now you have to use at your disposal so
maybe you spend a little bit of it but i
would encourage you to give some as well
and maybe invest some of that because
that can turn into a whole bunch more
money down the road in your retirement
george is exactly right so aaron when
we're dealing with um
people in baby step seven and sometimes
very wealthy people that are in baby
step seven which is where you are
and
they get a check uh maybe it's an nfl
player uh maybe it's an author like me
that gets a royalty check in the mail
and it's a big big old check like that
then you have to say before the check
comes
i'm going to set aside a percentage for
giving
a percentage for enjoyment
and a percentage for investing
and to encourage me to do all three of
those things and then like in my case
aaron what i do is i just apply that
percentage that i figured out uh to
every check i get now
uh because i mean above my living
expenses which are moderately low okay
but i mean i get uh in my income coming
from several sources i just get a check
in i go okay
what i do is i'm a christian so i give a
tenth tithe to my local church i got to
set aside 40 because i'm i i'm wealthy
and i must be punished by the federal
government so that's the 40 for taxes
and so that's 50 of the checks gone
right there that leaves me another 50
percent to divvy up among more giving
some some lifestyle enjoyment and some
investing
and i would encourage you uh to do
minimal life
lifestyle investing or lifestyle maximum
investing and something that might feel
even a little bit heavy to you on the
generosity side uh you don't owe anybody
anything
and where this money came from or the
result of whatever it came from doesn't
really matter to me you still should
apply to those three things does that
make sense to you
yes sir yeah but make sure you set your
taxes aside before we start having any
of this discussion or if you're gonna do
it like me you're gonna set aside 40 for
taxes
i set aside 10 for my local church my
tithe i'm an evangelical christian and
then
i got half of it left here we go that
balance helps them you know you feel
good it's automatic it's automatic i
don't have to think about it i can enjoy
the percentage that i set aside for
enjoyment because i know i was like a
grown-up with the rest of it and i know
i'm not messing up something right not
you know avoiding investing and uh
and so yeah that that's what you always
want to do oh and by the way that's what
we teach little kids parents to teach
little kids oh yeah we have our give
save spend piggy bank over there and you
can teach these principles at a very
young age exactly exactly awesome tim is
in hartford connecticut hi tim how are
you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i'm a long time listener and a first
time caller so it's hard to start the
call with telling you you're wrong but
if you're hearing me out for one second
people say how are you and you say
better than i deserve
with the amount of people you have
helped with the amount of lives you have
changed giving people encouragement and
changing their lives you're not better
than you deserve you are deserving of
everything you have and i thank you for
all you've done you're very kind sir
you're very kind it's a theological
statement i deserve hell and i'm not
going because of jesus okay so it's a
statement of grace but yeah i appreciate
it absolutely yeah and it shows your
humility but thank you for changing our
lives i got a 401k question for you
uh i understand the 401ks plan is for
the long term and we don't freak out
right now because the market's down and
that kind of stuff
however
knowing that we're in a bear market
why wouldn't i put a big hunk of my 401k
into kind of a guaranteed fund
to stop these losses for
x number of months until the market
turns around so that when it does i'm
starting to build again on a higher
balance not a lower balance yeah
the problem is if you knew when the
market was going to turn around you
would be running wall street
true true and i know you can't time the
market but obviously exactly
which is exactly what you're trying to
do
yeah i agreed um but i think everybody's
in agreement that it's not going to
recover
in the very near future
who's integrated
i don't know if you mean if you mean by
friday i agree with you if you mean by
september i'm not sure if i know that
yeah yeah true no we don't know that for
sure but uh
you know there's that the losses are so
big now i just keep looking back and
saying had i put it in this guarantees
fund i'd be two hundred thousand dollars
ahead in my 401k yeah but every dollar
you're buying now when it comes back
you're going to be 200 000 ahead with
you'll have more regret on that side
you're going man i should have left it
in there and bought more when it was on
sale it's on sale man true true i i
would be foregoing the growth but the
answer to your question is i personally
have not touched my 401 k have you
george name leave it alone i'm loading
it up i am tempted to actually put more
into the market right now but i as a
matter of principle don't try to time
the market so i'm not going to do that
but i think the market's on sale i think
it's a great buy right now and i'm kind
of excited
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
well on july 14th we're going to be
hosting a free live stream called the
real estate reality check
people are scared
they're mad
about the prices the interest rates
what's going on with the housing market
and based on all of their emotions some
of them some of you have made incorrect
conclusions
which are going to harm you
if you act on them so we're going to
help you with that we're going to talk
you through what's happening with the
housing market what is real the pain is
real the frustration is real the anger
and the fear is real
but there are also facts and data that
affect this the housing market is not
going to crash
mark it down i said it here i've said it
a bunch of times in the last several
weeks i'm going to say it again with
charts and graphs
that's a first on the 14th yeah i'm
going to
do something i don't like doing but i'm
going to actually show you the actual
data and
you know teach you so that you can uh
calm your butt down in some cases so if
you want to know what's going on the
real estate market george
campbell rachel cruz and i will be doing
this event we're going to go through
what is really happening under the hood
of the real estate market so then you
can you can draw your own conclusions
after we teach you if you agree with the
here's the actual data here's the facts
now you agree with our conclusions or
not based on that can you disagree with
data
i guess you could try uh people do all
the time
yeah they're called democrats so all
right open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you can sign
up for this reality check
ramseysolutions.com
ramseysolutions.com
reality uh on uh july the 14th it's a
free live stream so i've got a buddy of
mine that's a democrat that's running
for office that's why that was top of
mind oh nice i hope he's listening he
and i love each other and we love to
argue with each other i would love it
and so he always i did that kind of for
him because he listens and i know he'll
he'll call me now and he'll give me a
hard time that was basically a shout out
for him so i could i couldn't resist
just throwing little grenade over the
over the radio waves so the rest of you
that are democrats and now you're all
pissed off you missed the point it was
not a pissed off thing that was that's
called humor
and it's just for my buddy the sarcasm
detector isn't working david well it's i
i sometimes i don't hit the note you
know i don't hit the sarcasm note uh and
i don't use the font correctly when i'm
writing sometimes there's a sarcasm font
i think is that there should be when
we're writing comic sans so george back
to our last caller for a second because
that is also a point of concern out
there uh the bear market
and uh if we want to be a sarcastic and
funny we can say scary bear
scary scary bear because the bear market
the stock market's down 20 percent so he
said he lost 200 000 bucks so he's lost
he had a million dollars is 401k last
caller probably somewhere in that
neighborhood yeah it makes sense and he
hasn't lost 200 000 bucks unless he sold
it
uh because there's two two types of
games there's recognized and realized
recognized as i recognize that my
balance is down but until i sell it i
didn't lock in the lawsuit it doesn't
become reality it's not it is not
realized it's just we're just
recognizing and from tax purposes we use
that terminology accounting purposes but
also is kind of a factual thing that you
know like during the drop of 2008 and
the market went from 13 000 to 6 500 it
went in half it went down 50 percent
people were interviewing warren buffett
mr buffett didn't you just lose 83
billion dollars and he said no i don't
lose anything haven't sold anything i
hadn't sold anything i just it's just
riding down and ride it back up and of
course it went down from 6500 to 13 000
and then back to 39 000 from there three
x above so turns out mr buffett was
that's right the stock market in the
real estate market perspective is what
keeps you from making poor decisions so
when you look at that perspective and go
oh it went back up to 39
probably should have stayed in the
market thirty nine thousand dollars yeah
yeah
when you hand back and you see history
it can calm you down that's a good thing
to do it helps me
um and so let's talk about actual
history and data on bear market so bear
market is any time that the stock market
goes down more than 20 in value which
we're in the middle of a bear market
since world war ii
post great depression there have been 14
bears
that's a lot of bears yep
we've got a bear problem so um
and the
average length of a bear market during
those 14 is 13 months and the average
time to recover
back to ground zero back to where it was
before the decrease started
was is uh about 24 months 26 months 23
months i've read three different
articles so but it's right in there
right around two years
and so
if we go back to the first of the year
which is where we're measuring the
decline from
and you go out two years from january 1
of 22 that'd be january 1 of 24
the average is it will have recovered by
then wow which means there's a chance
it'll recover sooner and there's a
chance it could recover later that's the
average of 14 different events
and so you've got a lot of
actual data the chances of this one
being drastically different i don't see
that happening well it's not as extreme
as 2008
and of course the more extreme it
dropped so far it's not
the more extreme it drops the um
the longer it would take to recover
typically it would unless it just shot
back up due to some kind of a
magical economic pill or something but
you know so here's the story
you're
52 years old
and you're panicking because your
retirement lost 200 000 of your million
i don't know how that guy was i'm making
this up okay
at 54 you'll be back
on average
chance you'll be back by 53
chance you'll be back by 55. the chances
at 65 of you being down based on
historical data are precisely zero
calm your butt down
okay
that's what that says i'm
getting ready to be 62 uh i'm not going
to be using my money that's in the stock
market in my 401 k or my other mutual
fund investments um
maybe ever
unless i used it to buy some real estate
but i mean i uh
so i easily can let it sit there till
death and
uh it'll be okay but i mean the chances
of me statistically i'm healthy at 62 no
zero medication uh on average
moderately good condition on average uh
the actuarial table say i'm gonna live
to 90.
okay so i've got 28 years to ride this
out not 28 months
so i'm real comfortable
with putting more in right now while
it's down because it's on sale if you
keep that perspective and you've got a
long-term vision and you know so you pan
back like you said perspective
gives you hope people lose hope when
they lose their perspective
and the joke that we always used was one
of my daughters didn't get asked to the
prom by one of those boys
and that night it was a long night there
was wailing and gnashing of teeth
it was so very sad
and her mother and i were supposed to go
in and comfort her in her moment of
heartbreak but we were having trouble
not laughing in the hallway because it
was so dramatic that it was funny well
because we've been to our 20-year class
reunion and we know when she sees him
then she'll be glad
we have the perspective of time
right we know that is this this
heartbreak is not the end of the world
uh although it is the end of the world
for her at this moment but she does not
have the pressure of time
because she's a newbie can you tell us
which daughter this there's no
not a chance i'm just going to guess it
was wrong
no i i have a great poker face george
i'll never reveal that
it was bad enough that i told the story
to start with that's fair
but the point being
you lose perspective
if when you lose perspective there's a
good chance you lose hope
in order to think that the world is
coming to an end you have to have a
fairly short window that you're looking
at
because there's no long-term window data
that indicates that
only the panic of the moment
the flavor of the week
here at baskin-robbins
but you know that's that that's what
we're dealing with right yeah and when
you look at the data you know you kind
of get what you're looking for if you're
looking for panic you'll probably find
it in the headlines and you'll probably
find doomsday but if you look at the
charts and the graphs in history and
yeah you live your life by these
principles you can kind of just breathe
easy
the weight's not there when you start
looking for that
you know if you're in bitcoin
there is reason to panic absolutely i
could tell you stories for days dave the
really sad stuff happening with the
crypto bros out there are the crypto
bros are they're hurting they they were
declining
let's say we're gonna
there's the analogy
hey they've been rejected throwing
temperatures no date for the prom
sorry crypto bro no date for the prom
i don't think they're going to prom dave
they're not the type oh
[Music]
sad well we need to like form a support
group for them we should a dave ramsey
crypto bro support group make that
happen guys you know i would think that
if one would sign up maybe one
because they just wouldn't be looking
for a lot of mercy right this is the
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
[Music]
that's not right
can you put that back on home phone
thank you i screwed that up all right
all right jamie and deborah are with us
in georgia now that i pushed the right
button to do a debt-free scream what's
up guys hey dave welcome how much have
you paid off
we've paid off two hundred and forty
five thousand six hundred and fifty five
dollars and 71 cents whoa
how long did this take
64 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
79 to 110 000.
excellent well i'm guessing with the
length of time and the amount of money
that you paid off your house
yes we did
talking to weird people
[Laughter]
how old are you weird people
49 and i'm 48 almost 49. and you have a
paid for house and you're not even 50.
no sir what's this house worth
about 160 000 phenomenal well done so
the 246 was the house and other stuff
that's right yeah we had to pay off the
irs a little bit we paid for my car
um we had 15 credit cards that we paid
off we paid off a time share and a loan
and a discard mortgage wow crap y'all
were normal
yes sir oh man way to go this is a big
turnaround five years and four months of
busting it huh
uh-huh yeah whoa how's it feel to be
free
it's the best feeling in the world it's
just incredible tell us the story of
what happened and how you got plugged
into the ramsey stuff
well so i'm the nerd and i would lay
awake at night and i wondered you know
how were we going to keep paying all of
our payments how could we keep our
timeshare
what's going to happen when the credit
cards are maxed out
so we knew enough about your program to
know that we needed more income so we
downloaded every dollar and we went to
work
for the last 64 months we've been
cleaning offices doing laundry i worked
at the grocery store deli worked at a
honey store did product demonstrations
and for the last year of our payoff we
sewed masks during the pandemic and
that's in addition to our full-time job
oh my goodness
whoa you all been busy so out of all
these side hustles was the one that paid
the most
the office cleaning definitely yeah
that's big money yeah
so much money you make selling masks
um we
oh goodness that's one thing i don't
have on my piece of paper but enough to
pay off our last few credit cards okay
great so you made a few hundred bucks at
least that's awesome because i mean
that's a that's a that's a business that
is no more yeah temporary please jesus
please jesus it is no more yeah really
oh my gosh
somebody run that alien fouchy out of
town okay anyway the uh
all right so wait well i'm glad you guys
i mean i'm happy for the people in the
plexiglass business they made some money
so it's good way to go you guys
so man you guys you just rolled up your
sleeves in hustle hustle hustle so like
your mom and dad were people who said
work hard
oh yes and our grandparents too that
that whole generation
what was on the other side of this thing
that you guys were kind of aiming
towards the vision that you had the why
where you went this is why we're doing
this
well we have our 18 year old son parker
with us here today we were doing all
this for him he's he's been our biggest
cheerleader and our biggest reason that
we've been doing all of this
yeah you modeled that sacrifice for him
and that's ingrained in him now
absolutely he bought his first car with
cash yay
we're very proud of him yeah but now
we're passing down weirdness as a family
trade i love it
good for you guys well done okay outside
the three of you who was cheering you on
well our family and our friends and our
co-workers
our sunday school class at church
we've got a great network of
cheerleaders
that's good that's good sounds like
you've got good friends that are wishing
good things for you all the time not
running you down
yes sir we do that's good very cool guys
very cool all right what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
246 064 months
well i would say that hard work pays off
make a budget make a plan and stick to
it keep christ in the center of the home
and then the family
and i would say use the every dollar app
and don't stop tithing while you're
getting out of debt amen amen
so this was this whole exercise was very
much a spiritual exercise for you all oh
yes absolutely
yeah the whole idea of stewardship
managing god's resources well
had to play a part with the language
you're using
he has blessed us and we give him all
the praise and glory for it amen amen
well done you guys you're rock stars
heroes you have a paid for house and
you're not even 50.
you thank you so much did you ever dream
like when you got married that you were
going to be there by the time you were
50
no way
no
you know a lot of us got married you
know that are in our 50s and 60s now and
we just thought it's mortgages for your
whole life we thought that was a
definition of the word
you're always going to have a car
payment i heard that my whole life
little man can't get ahead you're always
going to have a car payment like eor is
your spirit animal or something
right yeah that's out there man it's out
there so you guys busted that chain i'm
proud of you
thank you so much well done we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story go
on and become millionaires and continue
to be generous and
outrageously generous as well
and of course a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and we're
going to send you a gift card for the
one-year subscription to financial peace
university to the membership to that the
brand new videos are on it if you
haven't been through the class it's a
chance for you to go through it or give
it to someone either way uh we're giving
you all these things you enjoy them give
them away help other people with them
you guys are incredible you're gonna
inspire a lot of people with your story
amen awesome both it's a great great
story all right jamie and deborah in
georgia 246 000 paid off in 64 months
that's their house and everything
they're not even 50. they're rocking it
did it making 79 to 110 and 83 side
hustles way to go county gown guys let's
hear a debt-free scream
three
two
one we're dead free
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done boys and girls
that's how it's done
this is a decision
it's a decision you have to live with
man beautifully done davey is in
louisville hi davey welcome to the
ramsey show
hey thanks dave how are you all doing
today better than we deserve what's up
in your world
well uh
so
short version is uh
my wife and i uh brand spanking new
newlyweds we've been at this for three
or four months now so short that i can't
keep time um and then not too far into
our wedding the lord decided to bless us
with not one but two babies on the way
oh my goodness
party yeah
let me tell you
uh
and so we've been you know we're in baby
well we
yeah we're in baby step two
but
you know so
my wife's a teacher and i'm a seminary
student i work part-time but i just got
my life insurance license so
hoping you know that that can take you
know that you know i hit the ground
hustling and that takes off and
but
my question really is uh you know like
we're
how do we pause as far as like you know
paying paying down debt and snowballing
versus
saving up for the babies uh they're not
due until december january but
with two of them you know there's a lot
of excitement on the way yeah well
you're gonna be making minimum payments
and kind of pausing the debt snowball
until we can stack up enough cash and
mom and the babies come home safe and
then when that big pile of cash is
sitting there we throw it at the debt
yeah anytime you're facing a an
emergency situation a potential layoff a
baby on the way that kind of thing we
always tell you to push pause
push the pause button and that means you
pay minimum payments you still live on
beans and rice
and you but all the cash that you're
going to be throwing at your debt extra
at your debts you pile it up what george
just said
and we want to have as big a pile of
cash as possible mom and babies come
home in december everybody's good we
didn't need any of the cash hospital
covered what is our insurance covered
what it's supposed to everything's good
um when we take all that money we throw
it at the debt and we push play again
but in the meantime you've got this uh
nice
cushion yes i like it's called
brand new married and two babies on the
way ah
that is storm and stork there's a lot
going on there
wow storkenstorm very
exciting oh my goodness gracious happy
for you guys wow that's gonna be amazing
but yeah you need a big pile of cash
it'll give you some peace right now this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here this is the ramsey show
where common sense
is for your dollars and cents
george camel ramsey personality is my
co-host today
sarah is with us sarah is in atlanta
georgia hi sarah welcome to the ramsey
show
hey thank you
um so my question my husband got some
stock options from a company he was
working for a few years ago
the money has gone from about a hundred
thousand to just got valued at a million
dollars a couple weeks ago
so we're trying to decide how much to
pull out of the company and how much to
leave in we anticipate it'll keep doing
pretty well but also don't want to be
messed up if we're wrong wow
uh what's your total net worth
uh
four uh probably like 600 and then this
600 besides this wow so way over half is
in this one company
yeah yeah we have a lot
yeah okay
because uh in other words you bet the
farm on this one company you went to a
horse race and you put your daddy's deed
for his farm on one horse
yeah that's right yeah that's scary
that's what they mean by bet the farm
now you don't want to do that so
um i don't buy single stocks at all
because of the risk of what we're
talking about the lack of
diversification
if someone is in love with their company
and their company stock and they want to
buy some i recommend they not have more
than 10
of their net worth
tied up in
company stock and that means you would
have no more than 160 000 tied up in
this
okay
okay that didn't sound like to me you
were gonna sell that doesn't sound that
okay didn't sound like you were gonna
sell 800 000 to me
that should sound like i will try to
convince my husband or that's what we
should do ah that's the tough part
he's getting started going but what if
this turns into one point five or two i
mean we could this is our retirement
yeah exactly yeah exactly so here's
that's what they said about bitcoin um
so the uh uh
another way you can talk to him about it
then because that's what you're trying
to do is to figure out how to discuss
this logically
the uh harvard investment newsletter
about 20 something years ago had a
beautiful article in it called sunk cost
analysis
and the danger of someone in your
situation is
that
when you're analyzing you have a million
dollars in a stock
and when you're analyzing whether to
keep it that way or do something
different
you are bringing into the analysis
the fact that you only paid 100 and some
change for it and it's grown to a
million over many years
it feels like found money in a sense
okay
and that's an improv that is an improper
analysis by anyone's
anyone in the investment world even
people that disagree with me will tell
you that's an improper analysis the
proper analysis goes like this
pretend like you had a million dollars
piled in the middle of your kitchen
table right now in cash
and you did not own this stock
what would you do with that million
dollars would you go buy
this stock
with a million dollars off your kitchen
table
no you see how that feels different than
what i said earlier you need to get it
down to 160. and what that does is
here's what that triggers in your brain
here's the part of your critical
thinking skills that that forces you can
go ahead and discuss this whole thing
with your husband and you should or play
this back for him okay
it makes you and when you look at it
that way it makes you analyze nothing
about the past and only the future
and you say what what immediately goes
through your head before you went well
no i wouldn't do that what went through
your head was something like this okay i
don't want that much of my net worth
tied up in a single stock number one the
second thing is um i'm not that sure
that this company is that great that i
would put it all in this one company
um
and uh you know
and you know i don't know i mean maybe i
would rather do something else with it
and all of a sudden the possibilities of
other things come across your eyelids
rather than just
uh oh i own this and it's awesome
okay so you can say you know it makes
you look for the only proper analysis of
an investment is forward-looking not
looking at how you got here where you
got the money is irrelevant what it does
in the future is the only thing you're
analyzing when you analyze whether i
keep it or not does that make sense
yes that does make sense that is a good
argument i might get somewhere with that
that's the sunk cost analysis in other
words whatever you paid for it doesn't
matter
let's pretend you paid pretend you paid
pretend you paid 2 million for it
and now it's worth a million
the same question will keep you from
you know because
that stock if it went from uh 2 million
to 1 million might go to 200 000
it could go on down right now that's not
happening with this company but this is
the reverse side of that same argument
if you're looking at a million dollars
and you're going well i'm going to wait
it comes back up because i paid 2
million for it a lot of people say stuff
like that right and if you do that that
sunk cost analysis that's a bad analysis
instead you say okay what do i really
think this is going to do only in the
future oh god i'm pretty sure it's going
to go down
well then why would you buy it and by
keeping it one more day you just bought
it again
you know it's the same as the same exact
effect on your balance sheet so yeah if
i'm in your shoes
knowing what i know from 30 years of
building wealth
and and i don't own any single stocks
i'm not mad about it i just don't buy
them i don't get tempted to
count on my own ego for picking one
stock that's going to be a home run i i
don't own any but if i did i would not
own more than 10 percent of my net worth
in a single stock so in this situation
dave this is going to create a big
taxable event if she sells off this many
shares
you obviously work with the tax advisor
on this but is there a strategy to go
we're going to stagger this out so it
doesn't you know shoot us into a million
dollar income a year
uh i mean you split over two years but
other than that no
you're gonna you're gonna get taxed on
it so you just put on the side a big
chunk of that money to pay the taxes you
know if you want to split over two years
you can
to reduce the pain and so sell some now
sell some more january 2
but i mean you're waiting from now to
january 2 in this current market that
thing could go down yeah it scares me i
i
if i woke up this morning in her shoes
i'd be done with 800 000 of it by
morning well it feels a little bit like
you're at the casino and now you're up
nine hundred thousand dollars yeah
exactly we're crushing it let's keep
going and then all of a sudden it can
turn on a dime exactly so that does
scare me yeah that me and you don't like
losing money at the casino we'll leave
that to other people it's easy for me to
not lose money in the casino because i
don't go so
um but the um
you know uh uh
it it's not the casino because it's not
gambling this is actually investing
but it can turn on you that fast with a
certain company and with a single
there's stuff going on at a company that
size that no one knows except five
people
that could the the news comes out
tomorrow on the ceo
did this or that my god all of a sudden
the things shareholders get spooked your
millions a half million yeah you know i
uh one of the saddest things i ever saw
in this was there was a uh procter
gamble which is a wonderful company and
i have no idea what their stock is doing
these days but years ago i had a
widow that had worked for procter gamble
38 years that i was coaching on money
and um she came in and she was just
crying and she had put all of her 401k
money and png stock and it was down 38
and so her 750 000 looked like
you know it looked like 400 000
and uh it was awful and she had lost
basically half of her retirement almost
because she had bet at all and she is
it's a wonderful big company but that
doesn't mean the stock is wonderful
and it certainly doesn't mean it's a
great vehicle for your wealth with you
can have a good company and even a stock
that's okay
or that has a good potential future but
um none of them are good enough that i
want to bet my half of my net worth on
yeah cool that's tough scares are crazy
you're never going to go public dave are
you no one's going to see the ramsey
stock hit the market anytime soon
because then that means you got to
report to the shareholders
uh that means a lot of stuff that i'm
not going to do yeah so sorry folks if
you're looking forward to the ramsey
stock it's not happening i you know it's
um it's it ram i can assure you it's
doing okay
it's uh it's doing just fine thank you
very much
you get all the voting around here
that's it i am i am the i'm the uh
sole arbitrator of stupidity and uh and
genius both so
there it goes it's worked out but yeah
it's i i
at least we know whose fault it was
right
one person in charge one person to blame
there we go
george campbell ramsey personality my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
thanks to austin benz zac andrew and
kelly in the booth taking care of us and
making sure you get this broadcast over
the airwaves to all 22 million of you
thanks for being out there on youtube on
podcast and on radio we love all of you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host george campbell ramsey
personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
that's triple eight eight two five
five five two two five
bob is in camden new jersey to start off
this hour hey bob how are you
uh doing pretty well dave how about
yourself better than i deserve how can i
help
well i wanted to get your take on the
idea of purchasing a home with a land
lease agreement as being sort of a
middle-of-the-road solution between
renting and then traditional
home ownership
so what is the structure of the deal
so basically
i would be able to purchase a home which
would be
and a decent quality smaller home like
two bedrooms one bathroom for
about a hundred thousand dollars which i
could
immediately pay most if not the entire
price and essentially have no mortgage
however i would have
to pay approximately eight hundred
dollars a month for the on the land
lease agreement so it would effectively
be a giant
um hoa agreement
and i see that as a middle of the road
solution between continuing to rent and
paying 1500 to 2 000 a month in rent
which i don't really want to do
or at the same time buying a traditional
home in south jersey which unfortunately
the average nice home in south jersey
these days you're looking at 400 000
which would
take on all kinds of
debt which and i'm a big believer in the
debt is dumb mentality so
being a centrist kind of guy that tries
to find answers in the middle i was
wondering if the land lease agreement
might be a happy medium for me
uh how long is the land lease
um i don't know off hand i want to say
as far as i know it would be an
indefinite agreement but yeah there is a
campaign oh it has to have a cut off
if it's if it's approaching infinity
it'd be a 50 year but they don't um
at least has to have an end date or it's
not a valid contract in any state
so um gotcha i would have i would have
to look into that more more deeply i
appreciate you bringing up that point if
it is a short lease a short-term lease
100 no
okay if it's a long-term lease
you can do it and the downside is
it's almost impossible for a buyer to
buy this from you
with traditional financing
fha va fannie mae will not write a
mortgage on this deal
so your pool of buyers
when you get ready to sell is going to
be small
thus you're not going to get much
appreciation
okay
the long-term land lease is almost never
used in a residential setting it's
typically used in a commercial setting
and it's not unusual at all to do like a
bill to suit with a long-term land lease
and you know a 25-year lease or a
30-year lease and during that time the
investor that owns the actually owns the
property so you don't own the property
uh you because the prop the dirt is not
yours it's you don't you're not
purchasing a house you're renting ground
and putting a house on someone else's
ground
and that that that that's the legal
position you're putting yourself in so
um
you know you what i would do if i would
use i'm going to continue to investigate
it because it's kind of an interesting
different concept and try to continue to
poke holes in it uh having done
3 000 real estate deals in my life
uh including a couple of them with
50-year leases on commercial deals
i would not do this deal
because i don't think it's got a good
upside resale on the back end even if
it's the best of situations
because it's such a weird
deal it's so unusual
that it's going to be hard to get
financing hard to get buyers off the
back end anytime you have a limited pool
of buyers off the back end you're going
to get limited appreciation
and it's going to make you wish you had
just gone ahead and done the other
regular traditional deal yeah this
sounds like it's better than rent to own
but it still has some risks involved
yeah because you don't fully own it well
it's approaching a condominium
situation i mean with a condo
you don't technically own the dirt under
your condo you may not even own the i
mean you may you may your condo might be
sitting on someone else's condo it could
be a two town home i don't own the dirt
you don't on yours because the town home
is one giant structure yeah so okay you
know then that's just a similar
situation yeah and so but the uh the
difference is that the that is a
traditional deal it's not a lease
in that that's a it's a condominium
document
um or in new york they they will use a
different document called a co-op
document but it still works very similar
to a condominium document but that that
you can get financing on yeah not that i
want you to get permanent financing but
the you want to have something that
can get financed when you get ready to
sell it because that's going to limit
your market otherwise if cash buyers are
your only buyer coming back in
you you know you're not going to get
much appreciation it still sounds like
this is kind of a shortcut i would just
go ahead and save up a down payment do
traditional financing on you know a home
in south jersey i would 20 or 15 on a
400 000 house and yeah do it that way
but i also couldn't resist investigating
it further just because oh yeah you love
real estate i always like getting into
weird deals and figuring out what's
going on
finding the holes rolls with us in san
francisco hey raul what's up
hey good
afternoon well good morning here from
beautiful california where the weather's
always nice and the
politics is always a poop storm
here that's a great tagline
how can we help today sir
well here we go we uh we my wife and i
discovered you guys back in november of
last year and we're on baby step two
and we sat down and and i sat down i sat
down and
why and i want to retire in five years
i'm going to be 60 next month
and we've paid so far uh 40 000 of debt
good and we have the big kahuna
which is our parent loan plus
two hundred thousand dollars oh
that uh we're trying to figure out how
to break that down we've talked to the
kids two of them that we paid college
and we told them that we were going to
help them out but this this was part of
their loan to pay for their college so
trying to figure out what percentage
they're going to buy in and
trying to see where they're at in their
lives um
i have a mortgage i have a uh you know
we owe about 300 thousand and the value
of the house is about seven sixty four
run out of time what's your question
yeah
so
i'm thinking of
does it make sense to maybe
pay off
balance of the parent loan plus with my
401k
since i'm 60 and then
re-input that um
through my 401k and retirement accounts
how much you got in the 401k
640 000
what's your household income
150 000 a year
if the kids aren't paying any of it i
probably would
it's tough those are some high interest
rate loans on the parent plus and you
still got 400 000 left in your 401k when
the smoke clears you got to pay taxes on
it obviously no penalty though
yeah what a mess i'm sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
well there was a pandemic
[Music]
there was a quarantine
there was the shutting down
of people's incomes and factories
producing
anything and everything
and then all
of the resulting
economic crap that comes from that
called inflation
probably heading into
recession
the fed decides to adjust
interest rates up
real estate market
slows
wild out there
more than ever people need a
sense of hope
with their finances
and maybe you're feeling kind of crazed
out out there maybe you're feeling like
i don't have enough i can't get this
done i don't know what i'm gonna do
well we can show you how to get through
these times
and the good times as well
uh there's only one set of principles
that work in both good times and bad
times and their common sense biblical
principles of finance
things like get out of debt live on less
than you make
save
oh that'd be easier said than done dave
have you not seen the price of gas yes i
just about passed out in the
uh
gas station parking lot the other day
filled up the raptor and i could have
bought a house cheaper
oh my god
have you ever filled up a raptor no i
can't how many gallons that thing is
it's like more gallons than your car i
could do the math on it it's just
bizarre it's definitely three numbers
involved i'll tell you that oh yeah yeah
it's you know it's bad when you have to
do like your card twice because the
thing maxes and shuts off oh and you got
a half a tank yeah i think it's got 125
ouch we're all feeling it guys and so
financial peace university
is how we show you
how you should have
hope
we're going to show you how to get out
of debt
actually control your money during these
hard times and during good times
and when
the courses are taught by me and rachel
cruz and dr john deloney and george
campbell sitting here with me brand new
videos all the way through the thing and
it is the best financial piece
university we've ever done almost 10
million people have been through this
class
if you want to start financial peace
university for free
check out all this new content
visit ramseysolutions.com
fpu
i know you can be scared i know you can
be overwhelmed and i'm not making fun of
you i get it i i that's very very real
and and so check it out
this is how you do it ramsay
solutions.com
fpu
elsa is with us in delray beach florida
hey elsa what's up
hey dave hey george i'm so excited to
speak with you and i'm excited in
general
cool um so the reason i'm calling is
because i was recently catapulted into
baby step seven
and i feel like i should know what to do
but i kind of feel a little paralyzed
with the economy so i have about a
hundred thousand dollars
um that i think
so this is something with and i just
kind of want to
be like the pros and just hear that
i should be doing with this money okay
how did you get catapulted
so um i was married and now i'm not and
it's for good reasons it was long
overdue and
i uh we owed a little bit on the primary
residence which i ended up keeping
and um owed a little on a car and
we sold um a home in
our old like area that we lived in and
the net of everything just caused
everything to get paid off and then i
met it a hundred thousand when
everything was said and done
wow
okay
how old are you
um 24. say again
44. 44. what do you do for a living
i'm in advertising
what do you make
125 good for you well done awesome okay
so you're 44
newly single 100 debt free you make 100
and some odd thousand bucks
and houses paid for and everything and
you got a hundred grand in your pocket
yeah wow
good problem to have sounds like the
future's bright to me
where do i go do i put it in the market
like you know kind of are you happy with
the house kind of thing
i am and um i have a son who's 11 so i
want to stay here for now because his
schools and i want to keep the
consistency there so yeah i am happy
with the house great you got anything
safe for for college yet you started
that
yeah college stuff is being saved for um
putting 15 percent in retirement
i have um some old iras which i actually
have um with an investment pro that i
got through um you know the the
um elps
and um
you know he actually
ironically just called me and told me he
was switching on brokerage houses and
said you know he knew that this home was
actually pending sale for um a long time
that it was going to be sold
so i told him i was like your timing's
perfect um and he's like all right cool
like let's you know set you up we'll get
your money market account and we can do
this and then i'm just like nervous
because
just what they've just said like we're
going into a recession and we could be
going into words when do you think
you'll use the money the hundred
thousand dollars
i don't that's the thing i don't have
any and i also and the other so you feel
like you've got at least five years that
you won't need it
probably and i also have like prob once
when my budget is said and done i should
be netting about three to four thousand
dollars a month that i can put away as
well but
my point is if you leave it alone five
years
if you look back at the history of the
market
uh 96 of the five-year periods in the
markets history have made money
right
and so that means the market's on sale
right now because it's down
um
now you've been through a lot personally
you're a newly single mom with an 11
year old
this mess you've just been through the
heart-wrenching anger the heartbreak the
emotions
and now you're the other side of it and
there's this strange calm after the
storm which is also a little bit
unsettling
all of that enters into the equation so
if you put this hundred thousand in
there
because i'm comfortable with you doing
that um
and it goes down further if you go into
freakout mode because of your current
because of all the crap you've been
through in the last 36 months
um
then and you pull it out low then that
was a bad strategy okay so you've got to
ask yourself are you emotionally
um prepared
to ride this market down a little
further if it goes down if you are
then and you're gonna leave it alone
five years i'm putting the money in the
market with your smart investor pro
right if you're not that's okay to say
out loud you know what i'm at a
vulnerable point right now because i've
been through hell
and based on that i don't really want to
ride anything
i'm done with rides
[Laughter]
i'm gonna put it in a money market and i
don't even care if it makes money losing
money scares me a lot more than making
money or then not making money
agreed elsa how much do you have in
savings outside of the hundred thousand
that's everything okay well i want you
to have a fully funded emergency fund so
let's park some of that because like you
just mentioned with the recession if
something happens to your job you're
gonna have three to six months of
expenses i'd probably lean towards six
months since you're you know single
income and that'll make you feel real
good about then putting the rest in the
market because you've got six months of
expenses sitting there ready to cover
you and you don't have a mortgage
payment so that helps a whole lot
yeah that's the direction i would go for
sure
um
and if you'd if you want to park it in
there you're okay
from a financial analysis exclusively
an investment analysis i would be
comfortable putting the money in there
to leave alone
because i'm comfortable with the market
being down knowing it's going to come up
i'm very comfortable with that but if
you're in a position you need to
remember folks when you're making these
decisions it's not just analyzing the
investment it's analyzing where you are
because personal finance is personal
you know
if you just went through a divorce a
death of a loved one you went through a
uh
very emotional stressful anxiety-ridden
career change
something like that you might not be at
your strongest point in your life you
might be
needing some emotional time off from
being brave right now and that's okay
it's okay to move slowly it's better to
be wise enough to recognize that to be
self-aware
and and not put yourself out there
a lot of times when people lose money it
has nothing to do with the investment
being bad it's their timing sucks
because of their personal
uh vulnerabilities
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchhillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today here in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
malia is with us hi malia how are you
hello how are you dave better than i
deserve welcome good to have you how
much debt have you paid off a little
over eighty nine thousand dollars good
where are you from i am from concord
north carolina awesome good to have you
and how long did it take you to pay off
eighty nine thousand dollars it took me
about six years and three months a
little over six years good for you very
good and your range of income during
that time um started at 75 000 and i'm
at 112 000. good for you what do you do
for a living thank you i'm in human
resources i work for an airport ah very
good good good good what kind of debt
was the 89 000 oh wow it was all loan
debt so car loans student loans was the
majority i had a little bit of credit
card debt
um a tractor loan um
so loans different types of loans okay
wow look at you a tractor loan what was
that for
so it was a john
you don't strike me as the john deere
type i missed something here well at the
time i was married so it was my
husband's truck
it was a john deere okay
all right so he left but you got the
tractor
no he he left and and he has the tractor
oh okay oh that was part of the loan
though before he left i got you okay now
i'm catching on oh well it all worked
out okay good
[Laughter]
so what started this journey for you for
getting out of debt and meeting up with
this ramsey stuff yeah so i came across
you i'm not sure how but somehow i came
across your show
started watching you was very energized
and just enthusiastic about
you giving advice over different
financial things and
started watching those debt free screens
and that was really my motivator so um
i
printed out something i printed out the
debt free scream advertisement from your
website like back in 2016
and
i put it on my vision board
and i was i said to myself i'm going to
go to his show and i'm going to do a
debt-free screen
so i'm here it's surreal but it's super
exciting you made it six years later
yeah
what enabled you to stick with us for
six years
through a divorce and a john deerectomy
and everything john derek and i love it
so it was really just wanting to live
like no one else
that wasn't something that
i grew up with or was used to
my parents was always good about paying
debt
and and seeing debt as a good thing but
they would pay it off but i did not want
to have debt i did not want to feel
chained to
paying someone and so
just
really just focused on
what would that look like and how would
that feel and it feels absolutely great
yeah it feels absolutely great yeah
you're you're a hundred percent free now
other than other than your house or
including your house no no no house no
no mortgage so you're 100 free of free
way to go congratulations yes thank you
well what do you tell people the key to
sticking with it is
so i would say you know i started out as
i started out married and so for those
that are married or who are thinking
about being married that are dating
seriously
i would say that
communication and just commitment and
agreement that this is something that is
important to the both of you
just motivation for knowing that
on the other side you don't have to
think about paying someone or paying
people or being i call it a chain just
feeling chained
to making payments every time you get a
paycheck
um and just prayer so i'm a believer and
the big thing for me was just sticking
with my tithe and offering
um
sometimes i wanted to use that tithe and
offering for something else but i
thought it was about priority and order
for me and so
those things were just very important
yeah you had spiritual discipline
financial discipline i mean you're a
whole new person yes yes yes i'm super
excited about that outside of uh your
immediate family who was your biggest
cheerleaders
um so i've been thinking about that i
don't know if i had a cheerleader i
think i was my biggest cheerleader
um i love my family i love my friends
and they will always you know joke with
me about not wanting to spend money but
um i was my biggest cheerleader it was
just something that i knew that i wanted
to do and that was super important to me
so i was my biggest cheerleader now you
make six figures and only payments
exactly
i love
i love it now you're going to be
cheerleading your friends
how did you do this mic drop here we go
tell me more i love it i love it i love
it all right and you brought the kiddos
with arkito with you what's your name
and age
marley she is 10 years old she's a
little shy right now but um yes i
brought her with me and it was super
important because i wanted to and i want
to create a legacy of her understanding
that is possible and that you do not
have to live with debt it's not
something that has to be part of your
legacy so i wanted her to be here for
that experience yeah just to understand
that it can happen and she'll remember
how uncomfortable the whole process was
that's right
from paying off the debt to being on the
debt-free state exactly that's it a
little bit of discomfort that's it
but it does it leaves a mark and you
remember that that time my my mother did
this weird thing and drove all the way
over to nashville to do a debt-free
scream on the radio because she'd worked
for six years to get her deaths paid off
it does lock in it locks in more than
you realize it so cross it off the
vision board you did it i know i love it
you're impressed very well done
all right malia and marley from concord
north carolina we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story that number
one best-selling book will show you how
to go on and be a baby steps millionaire
and that's where you're going now yes
and then the next thing we'll give you
is a a financial peace university
membership for a year if you've not been
through it go through it it's all the
brand new videos with george and rachel
and delony and me
and uh of course a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away to
someone maybe someone who's kind of
giving you a little eye roll earlier and
you can go oh well here's how i paid off
89 000
thank you very much i have a few people
in mind
good stuff all right count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three
two
one
we're debt-free
yay
i love it
that's so fun and we got a smile out of
marley yes we did
yes we did that's how it's done right
there
that that's pretty impressive um
here's the thing
when you go through that length of time
six years and three months and you go
through a divorce during that time
anytime you go through six years you're
gonna go through
there's gonna be some garbage somewhere
in that six years to be shoveled
um you seldom go through any of a sudden
we go through six years of our life with
only good stuff
you know and so when you gotta when you
got a schlog that's that long
um
it requires a different level of
persistence
yeah i mean you're you're kind of
driving the car and you're going this is
going to be a lot longer journey than we
once thought so are we there yet the
tank's got to look different and there's
going to be some pit stops along the way
and if you know that going in it changes
everything but man to see someone go six
years and three months persevere pay 89
000 it's almost as impressive as someone
who's super intense and does it in eight
months when you interview people that we
define in our culture as successful put
that in air quotes i talked to this
successful man the successful woman they
were successful
uh you find almost all of them have
one of two or three or two or three of
five or whatever uh traits
character traits
one is perseverance
perseverance
they just won't quit
another one's integrity
they're fanatical levels of integrity
you find these things popping up most
often in people that you and i and
others define as so and so is successful
well malia she's successful that's right
that's how that works
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
nicholas is with us in kansas city hi
nicholas how are you
hey mr ramsey i'm good how you doing
better than we deserve what's up
um i actually was calling in i was just
hoping to get some advice on maybe a
potential job switch
and so
right now i'm in the mortgage business
and it's a little hard
and i think this last year my my eyes
were a little bigger than my stomach so
i ended up i bought a car and a house
um but other than that that's the only
debt i have
um i have you know the ira set up 401k i
got some investments going on
but i feel like
i'm kind of getting in over my head if i
have no because i'm commissioned fully
i have no uh
i i don't really have many deals coming
in right now because it's
it's just uh
you know the rates are super high it's
hard to get
some of these locked in so
i have a salary
job or potentially a salary job set up
i'm just wondering if i should be
looking to sticking it out here or if i
should uh think about maybe switching
into something that's more stable
well what's the salary job pay and what
is it
uh so it's an asset based lending um and
so the salary would be around 125 to
150.
so like commercial deals
yes sir well
yeah um commercial lending and as far as
like uh corporate loans go
okay
all right
do you want to do that
uh i mean i so i graduated in 2019 and i
graduated finance and banking degree and
that's how i got into into mortgages um
but that's what my my dad does so i've
been thinking about getting into that
just because it you know it would be
commissioned eventually but
the the salary seems it just seems more
stable and
uh i don't know i feel like i'm kind of
in over my head right now
with the the mortgage in the car note
and well part of this
part of this is a career question but
part of it is we got to get you out of
debt
and so can you sell the car is it worth
more than you paid for it still
um i think it's about right around the
same
how much you know
uh sorry around 18 000 okay and the the
payments right around 400.
yeah i mean you can pay this thing off
and keep it but it's not you keep saying
you're in over your head i don't know is
the 400 bucks a month tanking you you
have no margin left at the end of the
month
you're also investing too and so that's
another piece of the puzzle
right so i don't want to pull out
anything from my investments and
obviously uh from like the the ira and
the retirement stuff but
um i that the mortgage is really kind of
okay so hitting me hard yeah so so
basically without refusing in the
pipeline the mortgage business is really
struggling because nobody's refined
because everybody's got a three percent
mortgage they're not going to refi to a
five or a six
and so uh the only mortgage is coming
through a purchase money mortgage just
meaning people buying houses right now
so the volume that you've got as an
originator's way down so your income's
way down um and that's likely to be that
way for a little while
uh that's not gonna fix in the next
three months um it's gonna be you know
it's gonna be a long hot summer
um so
um in your world uh so the um
the question though is okay i don't have
much income coming in i really need to
get a job or i can make some money
and then this other thing pops up
so i i think i do agree
that if you want to leave the mortgage
business because you're not making any
money and go make some money and go get
a job make some money i think i agree
with that idea i'm not sure
which job you would take though
i think i want you more excited i don't
i want you to run to something as much
as from something and right now it feels
like in this conversation you're just
running from something
right i think that's kind of my biggest
uh struggle is is depending you know the
salary sounds good because that's coming
in each month but then
you know i really want to be doing this
10 years from now and it kind of sounds
like no
right it sounds like i'm taking this
because i need some money
because i'm not making any right now
well and another
another big thing that i want to kind of
do is i
while i'm younger i want to be able to
have my money work for me and kind of
grow my my money but if i'm just getting
a paycheck each month and putting it
towards my mortgage and you know my car
i don't really have i
you know i can't contribute well i'll
contribute to the 401k but i can't max
the ira i
i can't really have you know any more
investments um and those will come back
i i understand that but so what what i'm
telling you is quit analyzing your
career
based on one piece of data as and that
one piece of data is income
it is one of the things you need to look
at
but you also need to look at what the
long term play is
am i going to be doing this 20 years is
there a progression here can i go up can
i can i move up the ladder in this
process can i make more and more and
more or is this i'm taking a dead-end
job because i need a salary shut up
you know don't do that
you there's other options out there
with what i'm doing now there's a
potential to maybe move up and own a
branch but then also the
the asset-based funding that's that's
got potential to then you know get
salary also and then start doing my own
deals to where the commission will then
roll in yeah uh and that's that's what
my dad does so you know i don't care
what your dad does oh and i want to know
what you want to do
how old are you nicholas
i'm 25. yeah okay don't take a job
because you're not making any money so
that you can make a salary
take a job that you think is going to be
thrilling
10 years from now 15 years from now and
your income will have gone up
and along the way you solved the salary
issue too
uh uh so
uh they tend to go hand in hand the
thing you're really excited about they
should be great at you tend to get paid
well to do it they should so i think you
ought to look at two or three other
things while you're doing this and see
if if the decision-making paradigm that
you're using brings you back to this
after you've been on this in other words
before you marry this girl go on a date
with some others
and it'll lead you right back to her if
she's your true love
and uh if it if it doesn't then you go
yeah she was just you know
i'm just
no so yeah i'm gonna stretch that
metaphor way too far there but um i'm
gonna leave it alone but the uh um
yeah so so yeah don't
only take a job because of income and
don't only take a job because of
passion and purpose and ignore income
yeah
that's dumb too i'm gonna send you two
books one is from paycheck to purpose
our friend ken coleman's book that's
gonna help you find that thing that you
can do and get paid well to do it and
i'm gonna send you a copy of the total
money makeover so hang on arsenal pick
up and i hope that book shows you that
man if we stop investing for a little
while to pay off this debt we're going
to really feel the progress we're not
going to feel like we're beyond our skis
here and part of that like dave he's
saying i want to invest more but i can't
because i don't have the money because
i'm paying a car payment and that's what
debt does it steals from your future and
so i want you to get out of debt and if
that means selling the car because
you're so excited about investing and
you drive a hooptie i'm okay with that
but you got to make a choice here we
can't be going in three directions and
then wonder why we're not making
progress yeah
and you know what he's experiencing
george is the old buffett saying
you know you you can tell he was skinny
dipping when the tide goes out
so all these things he was doing
was okay as long as you're making money
but as soon as the mortgage business
dried up then all of a sudden these
stupid things look pretty stupid you got
exposed yep you got it shows you it
shows you know you're when you're stupid
is stressed stress tested it comes out
looking
well stupid i mean that's how that works
and that's happened to me it's happened
to you it's happened to everybody out
there
and so
um you know if if you're making really
good money it could cover uh as they say
a multitude of sins a multitude of
stupidity
uh but as soon as your income dries up a
little bit or tightens up a little bit
all of a sudden you go well that one's
too smart well you've told you've told
everyone you've tried to out earn your
stupidity yeah i did i tried it it
didn't work because apparently my income
potential is not as high as my stupid
potential
so um which is infinite i don't know
apparently careful george sorry hey
you're a sharp guy we all know that
careful george we're poking fun at old
dave not new dave
it's different
i'm not sure what to do with that
exactly
but new dave is older so it's very
confusing yeah that's i was there's an
oxymoron in here somewhere believe it or
not i love it george campbell ramsey
personality our thanks to kelly and
andrew and zach and ben and austin in
the booth i am dave ramsey your host and
we will be back
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual
amazing relationships george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions the phone
number triple eight
megan 825-5225 off this hour in
charlotte north carolina hi megan how
are you
i'm all right thanks so much for taking
my call dave and george how are you guys
today better than we deserve what's up
in your world
well
my husband passed away nine weeks ago oh
my unexpectedly
yes and i am
he had a heart attack in the middle of
the night oh my lord how old was he
um i'm 31 he's 50. or was 50 i guess
wow
oh my goodness i'm so sorry
thank you yeah so we have two very small
children two years old and nine months
old
and
i'm just terrified i listen to you all
the time i'm a huge fan and i just
wanted to know
what advice you have for me what
mistakes do you see people make in this
situation and and what do i need to do i
just i'm at a loss
what decisions are you needing to make
right now
well the life insurance which thankfully
we had
just came in yesterday
so um need to decide what to do with
that and
decide what to do
that's 800
800 okay and do you have a house
yes i have a house that
i can't stand right now as you can
imagine
so
and what is it worth
it's worth about 700. we owe about 400
on it okay
all right so let me kind of give you a
general principle that we all use here
um and then we can back in out of that
and into that for
you know you and i can to you and i and
george can to figure out what your best
some of your best ideas are okay
um
when you go through something like this
particularly something that is um
when you go through losing someone
particularly suddenly and tragically
unexpectedly it uh
your brain uh
no one's brain
uh functions at full capacity in the
middle of heavy grief
okay
and so uh you got this fog i mean sharon
i've been married 40 years if uh
something happened to sharon my brain
wouldn't work good for a while you know
what i'm saying
and so um it doesn't mean it doesn't
mean i'm dumb it doesn't mean i have a
bad brain it just means that in the
middle of uh this kind of trauma
uh is the worst possible time to make
major decisions if you can avoid making
major decisions is that logical
yes
so for instance um
i wouldn't go on some kind of big
campaign to become a professional
investor with 800 000 right now you're
31 years old with two little babies
and you're you know
you you know
and
you said this horrible thing happened
and so i i always tell
people if you can let's just put that in
the cd and park it for six months and
cry
okay
all right i'm not making any decisions
for six months i'm just gonna cry and
let the fog of grief
go by
because uh grief comes and waves i mean
you'll be going along with everything's
fine they'll suddenly just hit you right
some silly smell or noise or something
that you know triggers your brain
triggers a memory and it just hits you
and you don't even see it coming and
that you know you don't want to make a
800 000 investment decision in the
middle of that so if you can let's do
nothing
okay that's first thing now doing
nothing is not possible because you got
to eat keep the lights on
you've got to figure out you know do you
have an income do you work
i've taken leave from work since this
has happened okay what were you
um i was a personal assistant okay and
what were you making
um 65. okay he was the breadwinner
okay
all right
and if you if you make
decisions
um
let's try to make decisions that can be
undone
okay let me give you an example
okay
it might be okay to sell the house
if you want out if you just can't stand
the place right now i take it he passed
away at home
yeah in our bed yeah
and so just walking around that house is
icky
right that's what you're saying i can't
stand this house that's what you said
yeah
so it's okay
to move however moving is emotionally
traumatic too
with two babies
dadgum right
everything you do is emotionally
dramatic
but
um but i i don't think i would go buy a
700 000 house today
so if i did anything i would just sell
and go find something to rent and a you
know a trying spot for six months
or a year i'm gonna sit here for a year
and then later i'm gonna make a decision
on where i want to live
okay but i don't think you're in it i i
would not be
in the state of mind to make a decision
on where i want to live for the next
five years
right so if you want to dump the house
that's something that the only downside
of that is you can't get that house back
right but you can get another house
later
if you just go okay the chances of me
wanting to live here five years from now
is almost zero and the chances of me
want to live here five days from now is
zero so i'm done with this thing we're
tapping out on it
so now i don't have 800
now i got a million two to sit in a cd
while i just rent and go back to work
and pay my bills or pull enough off the
million two
to quit your job and start a new job
a year from now and just set aside a
salary set aside 100 000 bucks to live
on for a year
okay but what you don't want to get into
then is grief spending
which is medicating the pain with buying
stuff
so you set yourself on a
like you like you say okay here's an
amount of money i'm not going to touch
like if we did that if we sold the house
and you said you got 400 000 equity
right
yes okay plus 800 is a million too
following me
yes sir your rent
you don't have any other debt right
nothing okay
and you just you just put yourself in
park mode
so you can heal
give yourself some margin to heal
and then a year from today
we decide what you you decide what your
career is a year from the day based on
your new career you decide what house
you want to buy
and you say out of that million two i'm
gonna set aside a hundred thousand over
here and i'm that's gonna be my salary
eight thousand dollars a month
for
one year and i have no payments except a
rent payment
that makes sense yes it does and you
don't touch the other million one for
anything
don't tell me your face don't tell me
you found something in the middle of
your grief that you have to do because
there's no such thing
follow me
because i've seen people burn through
this and and i've seen them make dumb
decisions
trying to be
stiff upper lip
trying to be strong
in a time when you don't shouldn't even
be trying to be strong you should just
cry move slow and just grieve yeah so
sorry megan yeah it's awful yeah sit
down with one of our smart investor pros
they'll help you execute that on getting
rid of the house as an elp
a real estate person and get a smart
investor pro for helping you with the
investing as well if that's the plan you
decide to execute on that sounds okay to
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right put your phone down
over the years we've substituted having
deep and meaningful conversations for
binge watching netflix
or scrolling through social media and
seeing how many facebook friends you
have which by the way if you didn't know
those aren't real friends
sometimes you can be sitting right next
to someone but feel a thousand miles
apart you deserve better relationships
that's why mental health expert dr john
deloney created questions for humans
these are conversation starters that
will help you put your phone down and
actually connect and have a conversation
with the people you care about
these cards are flying off the shelves
you guys keep asking for more topics and
we took the hint we have new
conversation cards brand new there's a
girls night out a guy's night a dating
a parents and teens
and a workplace edition spend time
laughing together learning something
unexpected and build deeper stronger
relationships pick up one or two of our
new questions for humans
conversation starter cards and start
having fun
shop at ramseysolutions.com
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and the new promos they run all
the time will save you even more use the
promo code ramsey and you'll get the
best deal today's question comes from
rick in delaware he says i'm 27 years
old and for the most part i follow your
financial advice i only pay for things
with cash or debit however i have over a
hundred thousand dollars of open credit
when stocks crashed earlier this year i
used two of my credit cards to borrow
twenty thousand dollars at zero percent
interest and bought s p index etfs i
thought wow stocks crashed i'll buy now
pocket three to five thousand when the
market bounces back and pay off the
balance
now the etf values are even lower
the total i had in the stock market was
thirty thousand and now i only have
twenty one thousand the zero percent apr
on the cards will end in october of next
year should i pay off my credit cards
now and take a loss of nine thousand
dollars or should i ride the wave until
the loan is over since all the money is
in indexes i have only two thousand
dollars in cash i make thirty five
thousand a year and i have about fifteen
hundred in monthly expenses
a lot of bad decisions were made here
[Laughter]
that's why you get the big bucks george
rick sounds like a 27 year old making 35
000 who thought he was gonna get rich
quick
by using credit cards to invest
yeah there's yikes written all over this
but we'll answer his question
proverbs says um
he who hastens
to be rich
will not go unpunished
every time you set yourself up to get
rich quick you're gonna get your head
taken off
um there is no shortcut to any place
it's worth going and so this is the
lesson of this
horrible tale
for this young man and for any of you
listening to this young man's horrible
tale um
[Music]
so basically you're going to have some
pain
you're just going to have to choose your
pain
okay
you're going to have the pain of waiting
and risking even more if you ride until
october
it could be down further
and you could be further in the hole
or it could come up
and you might not not have to write a
check for nine thousand nine thousand
dollars is a lot of money when you make
35 000.
however you can make 1500 a month
delivering pizza
or uber eats
and your little butt's about to go to
work to pay for your stupidity my son
uh because i've done the same thing and
that's the only way i got out of it it's
worked my way through it
so when i've done something stupid rick
and i have done a lot of stupid things i
have a phd in do um buddy
so uh when i do something stupid and it
cause me to lose money i call that
stupid tax
and you young man are getting ready to
write a check for stupid tax
the only question is how big the check
is
you can name your poison right now it's
9 000 bucks and call it call it a day
i learned my lesson not playing this
game anymore
over i found usually if it starts with
easy it ends with hard and he was trying
to make an easy 3000 and now he owes a
hard 9 000
because he wanted to take a shortcut
and try to
game the system every night when you're
delivering pizza just go
you know i hate the idea of borrowing
money on credit cards to buy etfs
i hate the money i hate the idea of
borrowing money on credit cards to buy
etfs i hate them i hate the idea of
trying to beat the market with borrowed
money i hate the idea and just by the
time you finish delivering all those
pizzas you will really hate the idea
that card's gonna get cut up yeah
and you'll be done with this what are we
doing giving
27 year olds making 35k a hundred
thousand dollars of open credit
uh we didn't but uh some idiot bank did
uh so
but yeah so rick you really have two
options i mean one is limit your losses
to nine thousand or take a chance
um you're going to likely take some
medicine
somewhat less than nine thousand
somewhat more than nine thousand
what is the market going to do between
now and october i do not know
um
i do not know
his track record
i think the market is going to come back
up but i don't know if it's going to
make it by october
i think there's enough negative pushes
on the market that
i don't know if it recovers 100 of your
money by october i
i wouldn't make that bet
i'm not saying i don't know i just don't
know
uh so if i'm in your shoes and i don't
know what i don't need is more pain i'm
probably going to
i would rather have a known devil than a
future unknown devil
because that 9 000 could turn into 12
000 bucks it could it could turn into
15.
uh before it turns into nothing i mean
it could turn into nothing that's a
positive everything's a possibility here
on the table but so i
i think you're paying nine thousand
dollars
in tuition to the school of life
and you're getting ready to write a
check and graduate with honors
summa [ __ ] laude yup look at that no it's
uh thank you lordy thank you lottie yeah
that's it so um geez yeah i'm sorry i
i'm not making fun of you because i'm
i'm readily admitting i've done dumber
things when i was exactly your age crap
i went bankrupt when i was 28.
so with millions of dollars in real
estate debt so
you know
you're a little nine thousand dollars
stupid ain't even close to mine so uh
you know i'm not picking on you i'm not
shaming you but i do want you to realize
and say out loud one of the benefits of
me going bankrupt is i figured out it
doesn't work what doesn't work and i
don't do it again i've done a lot of
stupid things very seldom george have i
done the same stupid thing twice you
learned a lesson i generally find a new
one to do but i touched the hot stove
and went not again but yeah this is so
the goal is to save up the 9000 by
october so you can pay it off no just
pay it off as quickly as you can put on
credit card pay it off now it's on a
credit card right yeah yeah so it's on
there it's on there just cash out your
cash out your stocks today you got 9 000
left and etf today you got nine thousand
dollars in credit card debt and because
you were stupid and you go deliver
pizzas and pay off your stupid
and work like a maniac and if you can
deliver pizzas 80 hours a week and be
done in three months or two months
that'd be great
but um it's gonna take you a little
while but you you know clean up your
mess and all the while going i learned
my lesson i learned my lesson learned my
lesson i learned my lesson to learn my
lesson
i was about that age when i bought gold
uh i lost five grand on that gold deal
that was about it because and i had it
all figured out
i was so smart
for a stupid guy
and so what is the mentality behind this
is it this well i'm going to i'm going
to outsmart the system i figured it out
yeah there's an let me just arrogance
every time you fall for get rich quick
it's
um
usually not every time it's almost
always got a level of arrogance to it
like i you know i understand that
there's risk but i am smarter than all
these people who perceive there to be
too much risk because i've got this
figured out
and there's always that that element of
arrogance to your
diving into bitcoin you're diving into
beanie babies
jesus well thank you stuff people put
money into it he's a cautionary tale so
he helped us out today yeah hopefully
stopping another 27 years rick is your
anti-mentor for the day
uh everybody needs an anti-mentor
bless your heart rick i'm sorry man i'm
sorry you're going through this but hey
good news is only nine thousand dollars
good news you're 27 you got the rest of
your life to never do this stupid butt
stuff again this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today richard is with us in
bethesda maryland hi richard welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave and george how are you better
than we deserve what's up
well just paid off 45 000 of my debt
totally debt-free
how long did it take you to do that
brother
right around 18 months good for you and
your range of income during that year
and a half
so i was making around 42 000 plus
another 26 000 with allowances from the
military
so through that whole time that was your
income okay cool
so thanks for your service yes very cool
what kind of debt was the 45 000
so i had around 20 000 in credit cards
and about 25 000 in a car loan all right
so you pay off the car or sell it
i paid it off wow man you've been
busting it
i have like beans and rice rice and
beans it's pretty much been that way
yeah 18 months you've been no fun
pretty much
[Laughter]
yeah now you're the definition of fun
you're dead free man i love it how does
it feel to have no payments
big burden you know off my shoulders
so 18 months ago you were live in la
vida loca and then you decided to you
know batten up the hatches here what
happened 18 months ago
pretty much
you know
payments
you know after i get my paycheck i make
the payments
and i only have a few hundred left over
to last me in the next couple weeks
and i had a good friend who gave me the
total money makeover and
i finally started reading it implemented
it
i wanted to you know change a lifestyle
how long did it lay around after he gave
it to you before you read it
about a week oh it's not bad that's
impressive you said i finally got around
to reading it i didn't know i thought
maybe it was two years well i want to
know because a lot of people say i try
to give my friend the total money
makeover and they laugh you out of the
room what was it
did you complain to him and he was going
hey if you're sick and tired here's the
book for you and he did it in a winsome
way
well for a long time he would always
talk about it to other people and i
would never i would hear him but i
wouldn't listen to him
and then that's when i started looking
at my own situation and realized i was
unhappy with it so i finally started
listening to him
and that's when he handed me the book
and
changed my life
man i love it i like this guy
what's his first name
dave way to go dave cool dave here's
dave there we go it's great i like it
that's awesome so what was the biggest
sacrifice you made it sounds like there
was a lot what was the biggest one where
you went man this one hurts
i'm sorry could you read that what was
the biggest sacrifice you made in those
18 months
i mean pretty much no fun
you know pretty much work home
only getting necessities that i needed
you know cutting out the fun excessive
spending no vacations
and your friends went dude you're no fun
anymore what happened you know what i'm
trying to get out of debt dude
well he's also one of the big reasons
why i was able to pay it off so quick
um he allowed me to live with him rent
free
and i offered to pay rent but he says
don't pay off your debt how generous
this guy's a real friend
he is
that's pretty amazing
very cool i wouldn't wouldn't be here
without him that's neat man yeah if
you're going to work hard and do that
i'll let you do this for free yeah i'll
be partying i want to be part of your
success story i like friends like that
that's awesome
well done sir very very very well done
love it love it love it love it so how's
it feel to have no payments after all
this work
it feels amazing um it's definitely the
new lifestyle i want to keep
um i don't have a house so
you know been you know saving up to
eventually put a down payment down in
the next you know a few years or so
but
definitely not going back to credit
cards or
what about the cash back richard what
about the rewards and the points you're
not going to miss that absolutely not
it's not worth it
wow i guess you can give yourself cash
back because you have money now
absolutely that's a good plan
i love it you're impressive man thank
you so much for your service and what a
great job getting rid of this debt so
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is that i already
ask you that
uh no sir okay um you just have to have
the mindset to want to do it you know
it's not you either have to you know
jump in the pool or get out
um all in or not
so no token
right
you know you can't just kind of want to
do it and implement just a little bit of
it you know
you got to be all in man i'm proud of
you richard proud of you how old are you
sir
29 sir very good excellent you got the
rest of your life to live with no
payments you're going to make so much
money you're going to do so well well
done you really really really conquered
a big issue here
very very well done we got a copy of the
baby steps millionaires book for you
number one best seller how ordinary
people build extraordinary wealth and
how richard will too it's not exactly
what it says on the cover but pretty
close
and
hey also a copy of total money makeover
you can give that to a friend like your
friend dave did for you giving you that
and i'm gonna give you a one-year
membership to financial peace university
and every dollar premium and the ramsey
plus membership and get you get you
started on the whole thing and let you
go through the class if you've not been
through it if you have been through it
give it away to somebody and uh it's all
new videos and including george and dr
deloney and rachel cruz and me doing all
the lessons and so it's all there all
our gift to you to say we we're proud of
you we congratulate you we salute you
very very well done richard in bethesda
maryland 45 000 paid off in 18 months
making 68 a year count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three
two one i'm debt free
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it's done
very cool
jim is in albuquerque new mexico hi jim
welcome to the ramsey show
hi daily hey george how are you guys
great how can we help
um so i've
gone through the class
myself and my wife and we we did this
probably about five six years ago i i
know what we're supposed to do i know
the steps i know everything's supposed
to be done
but for whatever reason just can't get
it done we don't we don't start we don't
initiate
we'll save a thousand dollars we'll
spend it um how do you get to that
gazelle intensity
well do you guys want it badly enough
because it sounds like you want to have
fun more than you want to be out of debt
well in all honesty i think that's
probably where we're at we both
sit down and said we're sick and tired
but then as soon as the opportunity
comes up to well you know let's go do
this let's go do that we end up doing it
you need a um
you need a bigger why
your your why is not big enough your why
for doing this whole thing is we're
mildly we have mild discomfort
so we should get rid of our mild
discomfort that's your only reason for
screwing with this and that's not big
enough to push you through
you have something to set your hair on
fire man you got kids
we do we have four kids five grandkids
um
we are our debt scenario if you took a
hurricane earthquake in a tornado and
they all had a baby that would be our
financial situation rob from peter
paul
how much debt do you guys have
um
including the house we're well over
probably three four hundred thousand
dollars how much is the house
debt uh
house right now is at three hundred
thousand
so you have a hundred thousand dollars
of consumer debt
oh probably yes probably actually i'm
sorry our debt in the house is 230. okay
what's your household income
uh 162. okay
all right
well you're right i mean y'all are just
lazy
i mean you're just you you know what to
do and you're just having
you're just too lazy to go do it
and so you got but the reason the reason
any of us are lazy is one of two things
uh one is we're just comfortable sitting
in our own poop
or two
um
we don't believe it can be done and
we're hopeless we've lost our hope and
the second one is more of a heartbreak
the first one's more of a you need your
butt kicked
and so
we're the people to help you with either
one
well we we can we can love you and
through your heartbreak or we can kick
your butt or we love because we love you
and we want you to go win so i'm gonna
put you in the financial peace
university and jim you need to put a
picture of these little kids on your
refrigerator and go they deserve a
better grandpa than that
and he's about to clean his crap up
it's about time
act like a grown man and stuff you can
do this
don't call here if you don't want that
we love you jim you can do it brother
hang on we'll help you this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
our scripture today acts 24 16 in view
of this i also do my best to maintain
always a blameless conscience
both before god and before men
benjamin franklin said the best
tranquilizer is a clear conscience
amen george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five allison is in cincinnati hi allison
how are you
hi i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well thank you guys for taking my call
today i have a business question for you
but before i dive into that i'll give
you a breakdown of our financial
situations to give you a basis the
answer
so my husband and i both work
we're on track to make about 150 000
this year our only debt is our mortgage
we owe 110 000 and that's worth about
800 000.
so my husband's a contractor he had he
opened the business about six years ago
and while he loves what he does and he's
talented it's very um
the 24 7 job we're constantly answering
calls and you know people wanting work
done and that kind of thing so we've
been tossing around the idea of doing a
purchasing of split house
but with that you know there's pros and
cons too
some of the things that we've considered
pros is that you know we're going to
have limited customer contact potential
for a big profit
um my husband can do most of the work so
the cost would be low and then i've
heard you say that health prices are
going to continue to grow
to go up so we were able to find a good
deal you know i think now would be the
time
but the con to that is um you know we
take a lot of our cash flow up front
and then the unstable market
the increase of interest rates and then
the waiting game to get our money back
so i'm calling to find out
when do you think would be a good time
for us to purchase that and do that
type of
you know
transitioning from our current business
to that type of work
um or if you think we should wait given
our situation
how much of the 150 was your husband's
income
um he makes about a hundred and i make
about
50. okay and um yeah do you have cash to
do the flip with
yes so our goal would be to purchase it
in cash how much cash
um
property
have about
60 to 70 000
um and then of course between the time
that we purchase he has work already
lined up so it would be several months
before we could actually get to it so we
we have the potential to make another 30
to 40 000 before we would even start and
that includes not touching your
emergency fund
that's correct okay all right
um i would do both
okay i wouldn't switch
until you've got enough flips going and
your flip business is proven
to walk away from the contracting
business and and instead what i would do
is i i think you're managing um
i think you can change your business
uh conversation with your clients
you know when i first started at this i
allow people to call me 24 hours a day
seven days a week because they were
having collectors call them and i you
know i was coaching people and they were
in trouble and they were behind on their
house and they could call me at night if
they got a collector call or whatever
and i i would you know i was available
anytime
uh now i'm never available
right
and it doesn't mean i don't care and it
doesn't mean i'm not serving our
customers um and so i i think you can
just say listen you know we work um
between these hours
on these houses
and anything we do outside of those
hours is an exception
rather than a rule
you know if you've got a customer coming
in from out of town
and you're building a house for them and
they only can meet on
you know friday afternoon after work
well that's fine you could go do that
but not every friday afternoon after
work and you're not available 24 7.
so you just go we're just not available
during this time and you just don't
answer
your phone
and that's perfectly
you can build a custom house for people
and they get their questions answered
and their concerns addressed
and um perfectly fine in a normal work
week without being available all the
time you just got to change your
customer expectations
you know we you know let me give you an
example of that okay a different a
different world but a different but
similar thing
most customer
service
lines are
the people on the other the people
receiving the calls are trained
by stupid people that say stuff like the
customer is always right and no matter
how abusive they are you have to put up
with them
if you call the ramsey concierge team we
will be kind to you we will answer your
question we will serve you under no
circumstances will we
allow you to mistreat our people inside
this building i have taught them to fire
your butt as a customer if you're going
to be a butt to one of them
i said listen we'll just give your money
back and you don't need one of our books
you need to spend that money on
counseling because you have a rage
problem and so move on you know and so
we just don't have we don't we don't
accept the normal customer service model
we serve our customers
while we maintain our dignity and allow
them to do the same
and so you can serve them without being
available 24 7.
i just really want a segment now where
dave takes customer service calls that
would make me really happy
it wouldn't like that to dave's point i
just think there's a lot of risk in
switching the business and you may not
see any income from this investment
property for months and months and
months putting you guys in a lurch and
so i like the idea of continuing this
side first yeah yeah that's true that's
our biggest concern yeah puts too much
pressure on the deal anytime you get
pressure on the deal you give the house
away
right
oh we got to we gotta move this thing we
gotta get our cash freed up and and if
you don't have to um you don't have to
become a um a motivated seller
and uh when you're in automotive
insurance
i'm sorry i'm sorry what's what's your
thoughts about um like the market right
now like you know i've heard you say
prices are just going to keep going up
and we've actually found a good deal we
think um a property for 42 000 we think
we could put
all in at 100 and probably sell it for
220.
um do you foreign
yeah i mean it's a lot of work that's a
hope that's a big rehab it is a lot of
work it is
a lot of work okay but my concern is
i think your husband keeps some
contracting going maybe he takes less of
it
and fewer jobs at better margins and he
sets the hours like i'm talking about
and you set your customers expectations
reasonably while you do this rehab
maybe you cut back 25 30 percent on his
side and then you do this rehab that's
fine but i wouldn't just turn one off
and turn on the other
whether the market's hot or not that's
not a reflection of the market it's a
business model issue for me
your business model should be that you
you need to proof text your ability to
do these rehabs because a rehab the size
you're talking about doing if you miss
the estimate on that rehab
it's an extra month
and an extra 25 000
you're about to blow your profit margin
right
and so
i like to do stuff with minimal rehabs
for flips
a heavy rehab is much higher risk on a
flip
because it takes longer and you might
miss the estimate
you know because i you know we bought i
used to buy these stinking historic
houses and they don't build them like
they used to thank god
you know and we would open up a wall and
inside that wall we thought we were just
going to you know run some wire or
change out some plaster for some drywall
or something and oh my god you open up
the wall and you got to rebuild the
whole freaking thing because it's just a
disaster back there and that was not in
the estimate you know you can't tell
that you open up the wall
and um
see
twisted lumber from 1902 that they put
in their green because there was a go a
building boom and they didn't even let
the lumber
uh properly could properly dry out
probably age before they put it in the
dadgum house and it's just it looks like
a pretzel in there but on paper your
plan seemed great yeah
my estimates had all kinds of margin in
them yeah but now you've got now i got a
whole nother wall i gotta build and so
it's just that i don't can't tell you
how many times that happened
just 30 years ago before 35 years ago
you can still tell i'm pissed about it
but yeah
but you know the uh is that that's what
you're facing so take your time
don't bet
the entire income of your household or
the future of your income of your
household on this one deal and let this
deal kind of stand out there on its own
and you'll do better with it
but i love what you're doing you're
paying cash for it you're industrious
people you're hard-working people
i like the plan overall uh yeah i i
think you're going to be great but just
do a couple of those things we're
talking about there and i think it's
going to work out perfectly for you
good hour george welfare thank you that
puts us our the ramsey show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you